Now, let's go back to our mass bouncing up and down in the spring.
You noticed I've changed it from being a horizontally sliding mass to a vertical one.
The thing I like about this picture is that the mass goes this way
counterclockwise though this phase space.
That's the same direction that we measure angles from,
so we want to stick with that convention for now.
Other than that, all the physics are the same, so let's say our particle is here, our mass is here--
that's almost all the way at x max and it's moving upwards so that it'd be may be somewhere here
and going up--this should be negative x max--that's positive.
Okay. So let's say this is an angle π/4 radians or we can draw a right triangle.
And in this case, since we've flipped the direction--we're not going vertically,
and now the cosine goes with the velocity component and the sine goes to that position
but you could've figured that out from the trigonometry.
Now it's convenient because if we want to calculate let's say the cosine of π/4 radians--
remember when we're using Google before, we were typing something like the cosine of 45°
and we're actually had to spell out degrees--yeah, that wasn't very fun.
Now if you type this into Google, it'll just give you your answer--you don't have to specify radians.
It assumes radians because radians really are more fundamental than degrees.
So if you type this in, you'll find that the velocity at this point is 0.71 Vmax
and the position is 0.71Xmax.
I've just plugged in the cosine of π/4 and sine of π/4, and for this angle,
cosine and sine happen to be completely equal.